did you ever stop to think that the
cigarette you're smoking might actually
be counterfeit that you're funding
criminals or that the coins you use
might be fake - all of which has a
negative impact on Europe's finances -
which every working European citizen
contributes the fraud can seep in
anywhere where the euro is in
circulation whether it's the diversion
of money meant for infrastructure
projects for agriculture or for other
European programs a European body was
set up in 1999 to recover the funds that
have disappeared from the European
budget
it's called Olav the European anti-fraud
office
Olaf is part of the European Commission
but it has an independent status to
conduct investigations entirely freely
this operational independence is still
subject to a monitoring committee
appointed by common agreement by the
European Parliament the European Council
and the Commission Olaf must also
present to MEP is an annual report on
its activities which will be debated in
Parliament
Olaf therefore ensures that European
taxpayers money is used in accordance
with its original purpose around 400
people work for Olaf half of whom are
investigators they all have
investigative experience in their
countries in customs in criminal
investigations or they're former
prosecutors and lawyers this is the case
of the Director General of Olaf they've
been for more than 15 years
public prosecutor in Italy I dealt with
economic crimes corruption crimes mafia
crimes in different cities in Italy but
open investigation Olaf must first
receive an allegation either from
European citizens or from European
institutions in 2014 for example Olaf
received more than 1,400 such
allegations almost 40% of these
concerned structural funds these are the
European funds dedicated to regional
policy which
to reduce the development gap between
Europe's richer and poorer countries
Olaf then concerns itself with
centralized spending foreign aid
agricultural funds customs the
marketplace and to a lesser extent
tobacco and counterfeit items we are
mainly an investigative body so we
investigate we try to find out how
things are happened what has happened if
there is a fraud or crime or nothing and
then we recommend the actions that is we
are not a sanctioning body the sanctions
like disciplinary financial or judicial
are taken by the competent authority
through their own procedures in 2014 all
as recommendations aim to recover 900
million euros that's just over half a
percent of the in use total budget for
that year smugglers are becoming
increasingly inventive this roll of
paper is stuffed full of smuggled
cigarettes one ships container can hold
about 10 million cigarettes hidden in
rules like this and that represents in
terms of lost revenue from tanks and
import duty around two and a half
million euros but do Europe's
authorities follow the advice of the
length mostly not always there is an
autonomy of these bodies to take
measures when it comes to the judicial
authorities which are you know
independent and there are hundreds of
them in Europe the results are quite
varied over the years and depending also
on the countries and on the cases whilst
when it comes to the new institutions
there is more consistency and more
our recommendation are followed in
addition to investigations of fraud
corruption and any illegal activity
related to EU funds Olaf is also
responsible for detecting serious
offenses committed by personnel of the
European Union be the officials
politicians elected as M EPS or
Commissioners and finally Olaf obviously
contributes to the development of
Europe's anti-fraud policy